quelle proportion des terres cultivées
de la planète est irrigué environ 20%.
et c'est superficie fournissent beaucoup
de rendement selon les dernières données
disponibles on en tire 40 % de la
production mondiale de nourriture
le recours à l'irrigation pour arroser
les cultures ne date pas d'hier au
Moyen-Orient une région particulièrement
aride des faux archéologiques ont révélé
la présence de canaux d'irrigation
datant de 6000 ans avant notre ère l'eau
qu'il transportait permettait de faire
pousser du blé de l'orge et des
lentilles notamment au fil de l'histoire
différents systèmes d'irrigation sont
apparus des bassins en Égypte pour
capter les crues du Nil des terrasses
pour irriguer les rizières en Asie mais
aussi certaines cultures comme le maïs
dans les Andes ces systèmes
fonctionnaient par gravité ou grâce à
l'énergie des humains des animaux ou du
vent par exemple
mais depuis les années 1950 des pompes
plus performantes et des systèmes
automatiques ont révolutionné
l'irrigation et permis son adoption à
grande échelle sauf que c'est irrigation
est très gourmande en nous à bien des
endroits dans le monde les nappes
phréatiques et les cours d'eau se vide
d'où l'urgence d'utiliser cette
précieuse ressource à bon escient ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas preuve aux
États-Unis l'une des surfaces les plus
irriguées ne produit aucune nourriture
car il s'agit de la pelouse